december 4th because that's when netflix
premieres selena the series it's a
coming-of-age story about tejano singer
selena quintanilla and only e.t is with
walking dead star christian serratos
who's following in j.lo's footsteps
i have to live up to jlo
nobody wants to do that hi entertainment
tonight i'm jennifer lopez and you're on
the set of selena
welcome
i love the movie i grew up watching that
movie over and over and over and over
again and
am a huge fan of jennifer lopez
[Music]
j lo and christian both recreated some
of selena's most
iconic looks from her white bustier to
her purple jumpsuit
there's the curly hair and bangs but et
has learned christian won't be singing
selena's hit in her new netflix version
they'll be using selena's original
recordings jlo didn't sing in her 1997
biopic either
i'll be lip-syncing all the songs in the
movie it's and it's better that way
i think i started working with a dialect
coach on my own before i had the job
and i started working with my singing
coach before
i booked the job and he also helped me
with the audition
the thing that really benefited us is
that my hair's not much different than
her own and i had already cut it myself
in an attempt to force them to hire me
and nobody else
part one of the two part selena the
series premieres in december
executive produced by selena's family it
also stars eva longoria's desperate
housewife's husband ricardo chivera
minus the goatee as salina's father
[Music]
i have to do what the fans want i have
to be
her and that's a lot of pressure